new at 11 Water Street we certainly know
the name and have seen the district
change certainly over the past few years
but now some say growth in this part of
downtown Henderson has just exploded
putting it on the map for people all
across Southern Nevada Sasha Loftus
joins us there live tonight with more
Sasha
Denise this area has always been known
as somewhat sleepy but it is becoming
the place to be in Henderson now changes
started a few years ago when lifeguard
Arena opened up with this new
construction many say the floodgates are
opening on Water Street
that's what's happening now it looks
like Water Street is the place to be on
a Friday night food people shopping
gambling uh safety packed parking lots
and bustling businesses both signs that
Henderson's downtown district is growing
something Brian Norris who's lived here
for 23 years says he's thrilled to see
it's gratifying because I like to spend
my money locally Atwell Suites a 57 000
square foot hotel connected to pass
Casino just broke ground this week
The Watermark a seven-story mixed-use
building under construction across the
street we'll add retail and office space
along with 130 Apartments to the area
just seeing uh the amount of people
coming into the area has grown quite a
bit Jordan command show opened Styx
Tavern here two years ago and says
lifeguard Arena has already brought him
more customers so he can't wait for
these other additions there will be more
holding people to the street you know
they'll be here they'll come they'll
stay here and they'll just spend more
time right down here while Norris says
he's eager to soak in everything his
up-and-coming neighborhood has to offer
you're seeing a Revival the Renaissance
of Water Street
now another 22-story high-rise building
is set to open just down the street from
here called the waterfalls that should
go in at Water Street and Lake Mead
Parkway and that is set to break ground
sometime in the middle of this year
reporting live on Water Street tonight's
offsha Loftus 8 News Now